[Applaudissements]
ok ok you're gone
si la gamme à droite
[Musique]
et de là
tu aimes bien qu eddie à ça c'est sûr
pierre getti c'est hostile oui c'est mon
style et j'ai la meilleure on s'adonne à
ce point là d'or se réalise là dedans tu
pourrais faire une histoire avec une
histoire d'amour d'un amour est en
baisse moi que voilà est-ce que du frais
la bêtise
didon évidemment non non mais moi ça non
mais non mais je ne veux même pas de
rêver à quoi il peut rêver
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour briser son nom
mais ne répond pas qui c'est on va là
répond mais nous pourquoi vous avez bien
musique d'ascenseur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette musique d'ascenseur
oui j'aime réponses posées de l'émission
mais city alors elle réponse positive
aller parce que ça vous intéresse
non mais je suis malgré tout va bien
choisi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste g dit allez viens on va me est ce
que c'est vrai que là par la ta femme ou
pas dit la vérité je n'ai pas volé et
pourquoi
ah oui mais tourné devant notre télé oui
l'icône là il a beaucoup tourné il est
fatigué on dit n'importe quoi devant sa
télé ne disait pas la barre noble ce que
tu nous a dit que c'était vrai oui mais
bon a dit alors est-ce que tu paies la
réponse est ce que tu veux la réponse
positive de cali oui c'est effectivement
une réponse positive c'est qu'en fait tu
ne sais pas et l'autre personne ne le
sait pas mais j'ai dans le milieu et ça
vient que de moi c'est pas réciproque
pas encore du moins
mais j'ai vu ce qui va les deux grands
frères être spirituel et tu en fais
partie ah merde ces patients-là ses
moyens
[Musique]
un baiser sur la bouche il a calé la
question en france
bah non ça se passe lorsqu'on rêve de
faire à kelly a pas mal faites vous
plaisir
bah oui moi j'aimerais bien a maintenant
là tout de suite allez-y
c'est nous pas sensé chose n'allait pas
enfin des ports les chevilles il y à vos
leurres dans l'équipe il y à vos leurres
dans l'équipe
oui s'il est vraiment là non il est la
volée kelly vdo bellion sané sera
regardé beaucoup ouvrent en mai sur
[Musique]
on met pas des jetons loin
je crois
[Musique]
non
ma mère
[Musique]
je me sens
chanter
rien moi la partie